hello everybody my name is marina
polishak i'm a software engineer at
microsoft research
and today i will tell you about wrestler
which is a fuzzing tool that we've
developed
at msr to help improve the security and
reliability of cloud services
so first i'll tell you about uh why
fuzzing cloud services through the rest
api
is uh fruitful in terms of finding
security issues
uh how wrestler works then uh we'll
go through a demo for uh getting started
by fuzzing a simple rest api with
wrestler
i'll then go into the type of bugs that
wrestler can find
and some challenges in fuzzing cloud
services
and temp permitting we'll do another
demo of how to do
more advanced uh usage of wrestler for
fuzzing real world
rest apis so
why fuzz cloud services through the rest
api
well there's been a huge growth of cloud
services in the past few years
both in terms of large cloud providers
providing more and more capabilities as
well as from
applications that typically were not
distributed in the cloud but have been
lift and shifted now and often
are exposed through rest apis
and most of these cloud services are
programmatically accessible through
a rest api in addition to possibly other
methods such as client sdks and such
and not only public facing endpoints but
a lot of private apis today
also are implemented through rest such
as
you know through the microservices
architecture and
all of these ecosystems are rapidly
evolving
so as you can see here this shows the
growth of just the public apis
being tracked in the past few years and
the question we ask ourselves as
researchers developers and security
engineers is
how secure and reliable are all these
apis so to answer that question
we really need automation to support the
scale at which all these things are
growing
so why fuzzing well fuzzing has been
used effectively
to find security and reliability issues
in many different kinds of applications
and it's highly automatable but how well
does it work for rest apis
so this is uh what we've been looking at
over the past few years and
in this tutorial we'll share some of our
results
you'll see that rest api fuzzing can
help find
service security and reliability bugs in
real services
and that rest api fuzzing can be
implemented using wrestler
to keep up with the pace of service
development and deployment
so our research started in about 2017
and we were mainly motivated by feedback
from
uh microsoft engineers all over the
company who were doing security testing
for
uh rest apis and so the feedback was
that existing solutions
just weren't finding the issues that
needed to be found
and that maintainability was
not something that was scalable for all
of the apis that people were trying to
support
so some of the solutions that were being
used were
one fuzzing requests and isolation so
you take the end points and you just
fuzz all of their parameters
and you don't achieve very good coverage
that way though you could still find
some bugs in input validation
because that approach doesn't really
understand what the service is doing
and the state in which it's trying to
fuzz the service is
like when no resources have been created
for example
another approach is to do traffic
capture and replay with fuzzing so for
example
run some unit tests or manually like use
the service and then capture traffic
and then fuzz that uh that traffic
so this of course depends on how well
your service uh use cases are
represented in that traffic
and typically that traffic can be uh
difficult to develop to
to the full kind of uh uh thorough level
of coverage that you want to get
uh and then of course for high value
targets handcrafted custom fuzzers
uh is something that people still write
and this can be very very effective but
of course
these have a high cost and just isn't a
fuzzer that you're going to write and
maintain
for um across all of your apis
so in summary uh the findings were that
for large and complex apis you really
need a different solution that's able to
automate more and get deeper into the
service
and this is what wrestler provides let
me show you an example bug
that was found by wrestler for
motivation
so if you look at this for a few seconds
uh try to see if you can spot what the
bug is
so here we have a client and we
have a service that is a
cm service that's creating resources
and so it's creating a resource named x
and we pass it some
properties in the body so here we're
fuzzing the valve property
with one two star three maybe that's not
a valid uh that's not a valid uh
kind of parameter for that um for that
property
and we give it a region and we get back
a 500 error
so this is already a bug
but let's see how much further we can
take this bug so
this is an error so we failed to create
the resource so this resource shouldn't
exist
and in fact when we run a get of all the
resources of
cm we get a 200 okay
and there are no resources created for
me but then if you try to create the
same resource
named x now with a valid value
and in a different region you get a 409
conflict
so what this means is that x is a zombie
resource
so somewhere there's x been created
but we can't see it and through
investigation we found that
it wasn't counted against the user's
quota so an attacker can keep creating
as many of them as they want
but this is clearly a resource leak and
it's a potential dos
both in terms of resources allocated on
the back
end to for each of these port requests
as well as just sometimes the domain of
all the names
that is used can get used up
and in this case it didn't take very
long to create this resource
so an attacker could just keep creating
these
until there are no more names
that are available so
to find this bug you need both valid
inputs
and invalid inputs and you need to have
these carefully crafted dependent
requests that know about a potentially
leaked resource
and try to abuse that so to address all
of the uh
challenges that i described with uh
fuzzing cloud services we built wrestler
which is the first stateful rest api
fuzzer
so in particular wrestler only fuzzes a
request
if all of its prerequisites have been
successfully created
and tests are going to be sequences of
requests first
all of the ones that are uh that need to
create resources to run the current
requests are executed and then the
current request is fuzzed with whatever
fuzzing strategy you specify
and of course the state space of all of
the parameter values
and all the parameter combinations and
the request sequence
combinations can be pretty huge so
wrestler has some strategies
to avoid doing redundant testing so
for example if you have requests a b and
c
and a particular ordering of them gave
you a 400
status code then wrestler knows that
this ordering with these parameters
well the service already handles that
with a valid error handling
response and we're not going to try that
exact sequence again
the wrestler is also automatic it
requires an
api specification uh so today we use
swagger open api to generate the fuzzing
grammar which specifies how to fuzz
the requests and the dependencies they
have and
we found that this is a reasonable thing
to ask for because
a lot of times the specification is
already available
since it's maintained as part of the
service and used to generate
a client sdks
and using the specification wrestler can
provide an automatically good coverage
out of the box if the api is well
documented
and i'll go into what that means a
little bit later and wrestler is also
extensible
so it has pluggable property checkers
that the users can
also specify additional checkers such as
was this resource leaked which is
the checker that found the bug you saw
earlier
so let's see how wrestler works wrestler
has two main
components a compiler and an engine so
the compiler takes an api specification
and produces the fuzzing grammar and
this fuzzing grammar has
all the schema information about the
requests it has information about the
dependencies
so what resources created by one request
are used by another request
and it has code to parse the responses
to be able to pass those resource ids
between the requests
the wrestler test engine takes the
fuzzing grammar and possibly a custom
fuzzing dictionary and some other
settings
and it actually runs tests and files
bugs
so it wrestler has actually several
feedback loops for analyzing the
responses and the error the status codes
and based on that deciding where it
should proceed to do more testing
and so it's doing this all of this
through a systematic state-space search
we have several options actually
for how thorough you want this this
search to be
uh and those result in you know possibly
longer shorter fuzzing runs
depending on again the structure of your
api
so here's this very simple example we
have a blog post service
so you can either get or post blog posts
and then you can manipulate a blog post
with these three additional endpoints
the wrestler compiler produces a grammar
which you can see here
and the grammar says that once you
create a blog
you have its id which is needed to
manipulate it further
and you can see that directly from uh
the paths in
um in this swagger view
and then the wrestler test engine like i
mentioned takes that grammar
and then it's just sending uh sample
tests which are these
sequences of requests
so here's what a typical fuzzing session
for this demo server looks like with
wrestler
one of the things that you should note
here is just how many valid status codes
there are
so this is um unlike other fuzzing tools
which can produce
lots and lots of errors and maybe not
very much
actually valid executions but here
in order to fuzz a blog post you need to
first create it so you're going to see a
lot of these status code 201s
that are each time they're fresh
creating the blog post
in order to fuzz it
here's another view on this fuzzing
session so here you can see that
wrestlers test cases which are sequences
of requests
when we increase the sequence length you
get more coverage
now with this simple example is easy to
see but this is still worth and
we ran some experiments to see this
coverage on
more complicated applications that it
really does
increase quite significantly like this
as the sequence length grows
so you can view this
uh this graph to see what wrestler is
doing to get an intuition for it
so sequence length one it only runs the
requests that have no prerequisites
so in this case it's getting all the
blog posts and creating a blog post
then with sequence length two now it's
able to create a blog post
and so now it's it's going to manipulate
it but it still runs a sequence with
uh one of the requests being the get
for which you don't need any
prerequisites so it is really going
through this
state space uh that you have for
sequence link two
and there there are more of those and
then for sequence link three now it's
able to do more interesting things
so the classes of bugs found by wrestler
uh in the slide
are actual bugs that wrestler has found
some of these are going to be bugs that
it's designed to find such as 500 error
codes and
the security property checker violations
that it reports
and some of these are other bugs that
are found in the course of using
wrestler
or by alerts that fire when you use
wrestler on the service
that you know wrestler doesn't have
visibility into so today wrestler is a
black box tool
doesn't require any kind of
instrumentation uh but of course when
you run it
uh you do get the benefit of uh you know
all of that
back-end alerting and standard
mechanisms that people often have to
also detect
additional issues that wrestler can find
so one of the first bugs that often is
found by wrestler is bugs in the api
specification
and the way that you would find these is
by compiling the spec
doing the quick start to run the test
mode to evaluate coverage
and i'll show you how to do that in the
demo and then you see that your coverage
for the service is quite low
so when you get into this you can you
can see that
in some cases a specification it has
under documented or
inconsistently named some some of the
parameters
and that causes wrestler to not be able
to successfully execute requests
um wrestler also uses the examples that
are provided with the specification
and if these are out of date with the
service then uh
you know potentially also
wrestler with with examples will will
not be able to generate
uh good coverage out of the box
uh of course wrestler has found many
bugs in input validation
uh where it flags off the 500 level uh
500 status codes uh authentication
is an area where wrestler can be used in
several ways to find authentication bugs
so one is you can just run wrestler with
an invalid token
and see what apis are unauthenticated
and people have have found some bugs
this way a more extensive
way to test authentication is through
the namespace checker
which is actually using two different
tokens
and going through all that state space
and creating
resources with one token and then trying
to access them with the other token to
see
if some of them are reachable with the
one that shouldn't be authorized because
they didn't create that resource
and finally we found one interesting bug
with authentication where wrestler only
during its uh
very extensive fuzzing mode uh after
some amount of time
uh the service became inaccessible and
wrestler essentially stopped working
because the authentication
uh script that it runs it just
terminated and
we were investigating this and it had
turned out that
this was actually due to a corruption in
some
back-end data structure that is also
used by the authentication so this is
one of those unexpected bugs that you
can find through fuzzing
where the fix for this bug ended up
being a design
fix to the api saying that
this just this code path shouldn't exist
you shouldn't have an update
through kind of the data level api that
is able to do something to the
authentication
wrestler can also be useful to find
resource management bugs
so it has found some bugs that were
resource exhaustion which it didn't
detect but were detected on the back end
of services
uh just through its regular execution of
creating and deleting resources
and this is a specific type of resource
leak that
uh you may want to watch out for when
when running wrestler
um wrestler also has checkers
to specifically detect resource leaks
uh such as the inability to create
resources after errors
or creating invalid resources
and finally you can analyze the wrestler
network logs to find additional issues
that for which there are no checkers
today
so as an example uh we found some uh
leakage of debug data types just by
examining the logs
and then once you know what you're
looking for you could turn that into a
checker if you wanted to scale that out
to more of your services
so a wrestler has been run at microsoft
on many of our services and it's found
hundreds of bugs across
the different services so far and the
great news is they've all been fixed or
in the process of being fixed
and with the resource management bugs
that it's found
uh you know we do warn folks that
it's a really good idea to fuzz first in
a test environment or pre-production
environment
before you decide to do some wrestler
fuzzing in production
all right i'll next show you how to get
started with fuzzing a simple rest api
with wrestler
so specifically we're going to be
covering these things and for those of
you who've already
uh cloned the wrestler repo on github
and gone through our quick start guide
you will see some of the same concepts
covered here so
feel free to skip to the next portion of
the slides if
if you've already done that so what
we're going to be doing is
we're going to run quick start to
test the rest api from the swagger
specification
and generate some config files and we'll
talk about what those config files are
which you can then customize
to possibly tune the coverage of your
api or add additional values that you
want fuzzed
uh we'll run the compile task to
generate a grammar from the api
specification and then we'll run the
test task to evaluate the api coverage
um then we'll run the fuzz lean task so
this is the
the first type of fuzzing that we
recommend doing
which basically runs a minimal
fuzzing systematic search to cover
all of the apis successfully at least
once and then run the wrestler checkers
to fuzz them more extensively
the wrestler checkers that it's going to
run are the use after free
uh checker that tries to access
resources after they've been deleted
uh the resource hierarchy checker which
checks that parent child relationships
are enforced in the service
the leakage rule checker which checks
that a resource
is not leaked after a failure to create
it
and a payload body checker which fuzzes
request bodies
after this we're going to modify the
fuzzing dictionary and then refuzz
and see what that looks like all right
now i'll be switching to the demo so
here i've already cloned the wrestler
repo
and i've built wrestler so we can see
here in the wrestler drop directory
we have the compiler the engine wrestler
which is the top level driver that
processes your command line arguments
and launches the different wrestler
tasks
and results analyzer which is an ad hoc
tool that we have
for analyzing the wrestler network logs
what it does is it bucketizes the
requests and responses that were sent
by the error message text so it actually
tries to
group all of these similar error
messages doing some abstraction in the
process
and what you can use this for is if say
your coverage is
very low you can see what are the most
frequently occurring errors
and try to fix those first and hopefully
get the coverage
up faster that way
all right so what i'm next going to do
is i'm going to run the quick start
on the demo server application
so what the quick start does is it takes
just your api
specification and it auto generates all
of the other configuration
files and everything needed to run
wrestler's
compile mode to produce the fuzzing
grammar and the test mode to try to see
what
how well wrestler can understand your
service and evaluate the coverage
so here we compile the spec
and the test mode tells you that there
were
five out of six requests that it was
able to
successfully run meaning it got some
kind of 200
status code so this is great in this
case
we can go ahead and just proceed with
fuzzing
so let me do this
right away and then we can go look at
all of the files
that were produced
so what you do to run fuzzing oops i had
to switch
into the wrestler working directory for
this
what you do to run fuzzing is you launch
the
fuzz lean command instead of the test
command
passing all the same command line
arguments
and now it's actually going to do some
fuzzing in particular it's going to
invoke the wrestler checkers
and you can see here that here we got
the same coverage which is what you
would expect and some bugs were found
so there are three seated bugs in uh
demo server
uh there's some invalid dynamic object
checker
issues that were flagged and there's one
500 that was found
by the payload body checker which is a
json
fuzzer for bodies that rustler
runs all right
let's see what all of the logs look like
so you can get an idea of how to
configure wrestler and how to analyze
the results
so in the compile directory you have
the fuzzing grammar and then all of
these other config files
which uh depending on what you need to
do for
um getting the cut raising the coverage
uh you may or may not ever need to look
at so
grammar dot py as we mentioned before
this has information about
um parsing responses and all of the
requests
and um how to fuss them so you can see
here there's an enum
and a fuzzable integer that are going to
be fuzzed etc
grammar.json is a json representation of
the request schema
and this is primarily used for the
payload body fuzzer at this point
you have an auto-generated config.json
so if you need to customize this say if
you need to
pass several swagger files or change the
custom dictionary file path or any of
these options you know this already has
a bunch of things that were
pre-populated for you
uh here's the default fuzzing dictionary
so this can be pretty useful again
likely you will want to change some of
these values
for doing more extensive fuzzing these
are just some defaults that
we've put in for you and then similarly
the default engine settings file may
have
some parameters that you will modify
for example max combinations tells you
that
for a particular request don't do more
than 20 parameter combinations at a time
so you know if you have if you can
afford to fuzz for longer
uh and you have like in some cases we've
seen hundreds or even thousands of
parameters to cover you may want to
make this value kind of higher
there are also some information about
unresolved dependencies
so what this tells you is that there is
a parameter page
in one of the requests that
pages are not created by something else
in the api
so if this is completely expected or if
the coverage is
high enough you don't even really need
to look at this file
if coverage is low you may want to
first anyway analyze the network logs
but then if you see that
hey there's a parameter that should have
been
produced by another api that was passed
in
you can look in this file and you can
further configure this
these values to try to say for example
that page
should be produced by blog
posts and the resource name would be
page id if uh you know i'm just making
this up this is not
the case for this particular app um but
if if that were
um if that were the scenario this is uh
this is how you would configure it
all right now let's look at the
test directory so for for the test task
the main file that you may want to look
at if say
you have gaps in coverage that you want
to analyze is the speckov.json
so this has for every request an
entry and the first thing to look for
in this entry is this valid property
so if valid is zero
this means that
there was a failure so there was some
kind of four or five hundred level
status code and you can further
investigate this by looking at the error
message or
the full sample request so here you can
see that
the request body has
an id which is passes a string and the
response says that
5 869 is not of type integer
is the error so now you would go
investigate like why is the string being
passed is because of an error in the
specification
or is actually the specification is
correct and maybe
there's something wrong in the service
or maybe there's something else
going on
and in fuzz lean mode as well as in
regular fuzz mode you would just get a
fuzz directory here
um we got some bug buckets so let's see
what those look like
so there's a bugbuckets.txt file which
has high level
information about uh here's the type of
bug
the bug was reproduced in some cases we
get non-reproducible
kind of sporadic issues so this is
helpful to know
and here is the sequence
that led to this bug so
this sequence is going to have all of
the requests up to the
buggy one will be valid
and then this put request here
for some reason so it's not always clear
from the bug bucket for some reason this
uh this failure occurred
so then in the actual uh
details for the bug by the way this uh
file can also be passed to wrestler with
the replay command and it will try to
reproduce the issue that's why you have
some
some legend some characters here at the
beginning of these lines
so you can see that there was a blog
post created and then when you ran a put
there was a 500 error for some reason
and
again this put it kind of looks valid so
it's unclear from
from just looking at this message and
this body
what might have gone wrong this looks
like a valid json payload you would have
to
investigate further with what's actually
going on in the service in this case
all right next we're going to see how to
customize the fuzzing dictionary
so i'm going to change the dictionary
and introduce
a custom payload for the body parameter
so custom payload remember means that
we're going to specifically fuzz the
bodies with these values that i'll
provide in the dictionary here
so what you want to do is you'll want to
copy
the dictionary out of the compile folder
which actually will get overwritten each
time you compile
and then you also want to copy the
config
out of the compile folder since you'll
be changing that
next we will see how to update these so
in the config
you'll want to change from the default
dictionary to
the one where we uh just copied
the dictionary and
in the dictionary we're going to add a
wrestler custom payload
for body and let's give it a couple of
values like first
blog and
second blog and then if we want to get
creative we can also
give it one of these unquoted payloads
let's give it something like
third blog
pull in
d one
one so here we're gonna
try to inject a parameter
let's see third blog
id1
and this needs to be body
there we go all right
so this is the dictionary so we've added
here a custom payload called body
unquoted just means that it will
use it as a raw string it won't put
quotes around it
while the regular custom payload it'll
take into account whatever type
the original parameter was and it'll
quote or not
quote it based on that data type so for
example it'll quote strings but not
integers
all right let's see what happens when we
compile this
so
compile i'm going to compile the config
and now you can see in the compile
directory
when you look at the grammar it will
have
an updated wrestler custom payload
for the body two of the requests
take a body as a parameter the post and
the put i believe
and both of them will have this wrestler
custom payload
let's see what happens when these
payloads are fuzzed
so let's actually first launch test mode
so we're launching test mode and here we
can
make sure the updated dictionary
is there although in the grammar now the
updated dictionary has been copied there
because that's what you listed in the
config
so let's see what happens when we test
out
this new custom payload and now we can
see that
hey the coverage seems to be now 100
percent
uh six out of six requests so what
happened here
let's see
see that in the network log
remember we had three types of blog the
first
the second and the third and so what
test mode does is it tries to cover each
request successfully once
so what that means is if let's say there
are three parameter values
for body in this case this put request
that was failing
it will try the first parameter and then
because it failed it will try the second
parameter and because it failed again it
will try the third parameter
while if it succeeded the first time it
actually will not try all those
combinations in test mode
it will try them in fuzzy mode but the
purpose of test mode is just to make
sure
uh that the basic setup is correct so it
only tries
uh until it finds that first
valid payload so let's see if we have
first blog so here we have first blog
and we had a 201 created so none of the
other values were tried
let's see where second blog was tried
so here we can see we're actually
sending a payload of the second blog
so we sent the first blog and we
received two one created
this is for the post and now for the put
we have second blog
because the first one we already failed
the second blog also failed
and now we're going to try third blog
so here is a third blog and here
this actually succeeded so what happened
here is
if you remember from the earlier spec
coverage
we had an error saying that id is a
string
and input validation failed and so here
what we've done is in the custom payload
we've injected
this additional id parameter and we made
it an integer
but look the string id parameter is
still here
and interestingly the server now accepts
this payload which has these two
duplicated id parameters
so you know even though coverage has
increased uh
now wrestler happily can fuzz this still
may be an issue that you might want to
take a look at
so you can get some ideas for how you
can use these uh raw custom payloads
to uh to run some of these more
more interesting tests all right
this concludes the first part of our
getting started demo
and now let's talk about some of the
challenges that arise when fuzzing real
world cloud services
so the first thing you'll probably see
that the
demo script didn't do is
authentication so for a real world api
you're going to have to provide some
kind of authentication
to wrestler and we support primarily
token-based authentication
i'll show you how to do that later in
the demo if you do need
some other types of authentication
please talk to us on github
and we'll do our best to support your
use case
we do support some other authentication
options you can check them out
in in the documentation
so the next thing that comes up with
cloud service rest apis
is dependencies both between the
requests in the same
api specification or in some cases you
need to create resources and they're
created by a totally different api
so wrestler has some ways for you to
combine different specifications and to
specify
that hey when i run the compiler i want
to have access to
all of these different request types so
i can properly infer dependencies but
then i only want to fuzz
this one resource so we provide support
for you
with regular expressions to do that
and another related issue that comes up
is about pre-provisioning resources so
typically if there is some for example
database that you expect to be available
um that isn't populated by the api
um you know that that will be an issue
for wrestler of course it knows nothing
about it
um we hope that
other automation that you already have
other testing to
support automatically testing the same
api
can also be leveraged for pre-populating
necessary resources for wrestler but
this is something that
uh occasionally you know uh can can be a
problem
that for example if you pre-provision
resources but then
the api somehow modifies those resources
such that they have to be cleaned up
every time
um before uh
before executing some of the requests
uh so we don't provide support for that
in wrestler today
if if you have that use case definitely
reach out to us
again and we'll try to see what we can
do
naming constraints is another
interesting area that comes up
in real services so for example if
you need to create new resources that
can only be you know at most uh 10
characters long the names
or they have to be you know some type
they have to be a grid for example
uh wrestler has some support for this uh
we definitely
haven't seen all the possible patterns
uh but this is an area where uh
often coverage can be low because of
something that is
api specific and really affects like all
the resources in your api
um and again we're happy to support more
cases like that as they come up
um but uh a lot of times uh
this type of thing really has to be
supported in the tool
itself uh resource creation patterns
is uh also pretty interesting area that
um you know we're still we're still
exploring and
adding support for so like
asynchronously created resources
um can take a very long time to actually
appear
so the question is uh should you fuzz
that resource like
as it's transitioning to being uh being
ready
and how long should you wait and um
you know is it reasonable to wait uh for
that resource every time
so wrestler provides an option that
allows you
to first customize how long you're
waiting for such resources
and secondly decide that
hey for such resources that are maybe
very expensive to create
you're going to actually only create
them once and just avoid fuzzing them
um and then fuzz them through you know
some other mechanism outside of wrestler
or possibly by using uh
mocks uh and running wrestler with with
those mocks and those resources
separately
and then another challenging case is
rate limited resources
or just uh resource limits like
i can only create you know five of a
resource depending on the type of
account that i have
so we have some knobs that you can use
to indirectly
get this to work in in wrestler but
these type of patterns are
often difficult to deal with and with a
real service
you may not be able to just turn those
off for your testing but if you can that
would be really
kind of the most effective way to at
least
get get all the other parts of the api
fuzzed
and there are many other challenges so
uh you know we're actively exploring how
to
improve the automation and wrestler
improve the coverage that it gets out of
the box
and uh we're very curious to hear from
you about
um what challenges you see so
i'll be switching to my second demo now
to show you
uh how to use some of the more advanced
features of a wrestler
that you may require for fuzzing real
cloud services
so in the demo i'm going to show how to
set up authentication
uh how to provide api payload examples
and how to configure custom dependencies
when wrestler can't infer them
automatically
first let's see how authentication works
in wrestler so wrestler supports token
based authentication
and we give you two command line options
that allow you to control
how to uh both get the token
for your for your service as well as how
often to refresh the tokens
so let's see what those look like let's
say we had
the command line for the test mode of
demo server
which is the first time that you're
going to be trying out your
authentication
here we specified two additional
parameters
one is token refresh command
and this contains this command line that
fetches and prints out the token and the
token refresh interval
so when we ran this on demo server it
looks like it was just ignoring this
extra authentication
information that we were passing it
because the coverage is still
just as good and
let me show you really quickly
what actually is printed by this get
token command so here
in this case there were two tokens that
we fetched for alice and bob
and here they are printed on separate
lines
everything in wrestler except the
namespace checker is only going to use
one of these tokens but for the
namespace checker we really we do
check that uh resources created by alice
then cannot be accessed by bob
all right now let's see what this
execution looks like in the logs
so here if you've configured everything
correctly you should see
as the first thing in the network log
printed will refresh the token here is
the command
and here is the new value and this
omitted auth token
this is actually a wrestler um
removing the specific token so they
aren't persisted in the logs
uh just to make it easier to share the
logs
um without having having these
token values in there all right
so this is how authentication works i'll
next
talk about how to specify example
payloads in wrestler
so example payloads are a quick way for
you to increase coverage and also just
test out whether what the behavior is
for different payloads
without you know doing a lot of
manipulation of the dictionary
or you know manually changing the spec
or the grammar
so the way that example payloads work is
in your compiler configuration
you can specify an additional
option called example config file path
and through this option you will provide
uh some external examples now your
uh specification your your swagger open
api specification may already have
example references that it's using
in which case you may already be getting
some of the benefits of examples
that i'll talk about in a minute but
this is a way for you to completely
override
any such examples and say instead of the
example values
in the swagger spec or the schema use
the values and the schema that's
provided in in these examples
so let's go look at what this example
uh config file looks like
server config examples
so here this mirrors the open api
specification so you have
paths you have the specific
endpoints then you have the method and
then here you just have you can give
these names you know like one
um and then you're gonna have parameters
and then possibly responses and maybe in
the future we'll put some other things
here
so here i've specified that the payload
parameter which is the body
for the blog post service
that it's going to have an id and some
tags
now if you remember in the schema there
was an id
and then a body parameter and in fact in
the dictionary we had some
custom payload for this body now the
fact that you've used
the fact that you're using the example
here
uh means that wrestler is going to take
this and say okay
what in this example matches my schema
so it still does use the schema in the
specification to validate this
and it says okay schema has an id so i'm
going to use id
the schema doesn't have this tags so i'm
just going to ignore this
and then the body parameter it's going
to say well this example didn't have a
body parameter
so i'm not going to use a body parameter
for
the primary search mode of wrestler i'm
going to use it
um for still for fuzzing with the
payload body checker which uses always
the full schema
but in this case it's uh it's not going
to use body to get that initial
test run working to make sure that
wrestler understands
all of the um
request types so this can be very
helpful if say
uh your payload has like hundreds or
even a thousand properties
and you know but really it's so it's
possible to
uh to get to create the resource using
you know just one or two of those
properties you can specify this quickly
in an example and we support both inline
ones
and as well as a file reference so this
is the examples we've specified it
in the config we're going to use the
same dictionary
so we do need to recompile because like
i mentioned there's a schema change
and let's see what this is going to look
like
compile config
all right so in compile
let's go to the grammar
and let's see
here so in the grammar you actually see
this id
hard coded to one two three four five
which is exactly
the value if you remember from the
examples
so this is this is what it means to use
and now let's look at a
test just to make sure
so here and test if you remember um
the coverage was before 100 and now that
we've actually recompiled it we see that
well this example actually turned out to
be not very helpful in this case and it
reduced our coverage
so you get the basic idea this is uh
this is how to use examples
in this last demo let's see how to
specify producer consumer annotations to
wrestler
so remember producer consumer
dependencies
are what the wrestler compiler infers to
know what sequences of requests to
execute
in order to create all of the
prerequisites for each request
that we're trying to cover throughout
fuzzing
so here this swagger specification for
the demo server
this was already pretty high quality
because wrestler was able to achieve
almost 100 coverage out of the box so
i'm going to rename
one of the path parameters here to
cause wrestler not to be able to infer
producer consumer dependency
so i'm going to rename this post id
parameter to
post and now wrestler won't be able to
infer that when a blog post is created
it returns the id in the response and
then that id
should be the id specified in the
put get and delete requests
so let's run the wrestler compiler and
see what happens once this is
run changed
and so how would you know that your
coverage is not very good well you would
have actually run the test mode
in fact you can do that quickly here
to show you how you might investigate
that so you have two options here you
can either
after the compile look through the
grammar and make sure things look okay
this is once you have more experience
with wrestler this is something you can
do
or in most cases you would just go ahead
and look at coverage so now here the
coverage is 50
which is still reasonable but we know
that
we can do a lot better so let's let's
look at what happened here
so when you go and look at the network
logs
you can see that the put actually we can
look at the spec coverage file
this will be a little bit faster let's
see what the
invalid requests were so the delete
failed
the get failed and the put failed let's
look at the put request
and it looks like we're getting an error
message that's
uh not even json
and the request body
looks pretty good here
and the request uri however now has this
uh strange looking id
so maybe this is what's causing the
problem
so let's look at why that's that idea is
being passed here
so we can look at the grammar
and we can see that here
the grammar contains the id dynamic
variable
that corresponds to the posts
creating the blog and this is
indicated by the writer so this is the
producer part of the producer consumer
dependency
but when we look at the put request we
see that what's plugged in here
isn't that id you would see a reader if
that were the case
but it's this custom payload uuid 4
suffix
so what this means is it means that
wrestler now thinks that
put is also creating blog posts
which in this case is not correct and
most likely the service doesn't accept
just this arbitrary id for the put and
it's uh it's
returning some error so
let's see how we can work around this if
let's say you you were not the one
maintaining the swagger specification
and um couldn't necessarily update the
names
the names there to improve it right away
but wanted to fuzz with wrestler
so what we're going to do is create a
producer consumer annotation
uh the quickest way to do that is to go
to thisdependencies.json file
and find the request in question so we
have the put request
and then find the path parameters so
here there's just one path parameter
and this is what the producer consumer
annotation looks like
so here you can see there is no producer
endpoint method
and wrestler thought that you know a new
resource is being created so just
give it a producer resource name
and we're going to put this into an
annotations.json file so this is our
template
and then of course modify it
so that it's actually does what we need
so consumer param is the post
the producer resource name this is the
name
of the property that comes from the
response
the producer method in this case is post
and then blog posts is the endpoint
and then we also need to make sure that
the config is updated with the path for
the annotations looks like it's
not there yet annotation file path
we specify the path to these annotations
and now let's recompile
and see what happens
actually we can go ahead and retest as
well
so when you've recompiled now when you
look at the grammar
the same blog post id we can search for
reader
and now all of these uh delete
put and get now all correctly have
the id that's received from the response
of the post
and then test is also back to our good
coverage number that we wanted
all right this concludes the demo for
finding
more information about how wrestler
works under the covers
please look at some of our research
papers so we have four publications
linked
below in the slide and our github
documentation also has a lot of details
that that can help you get started
fuzzing your rest apis
thank you so much for attending this
webinar and please give us feedback
as well as i'm happy to stay around for
q a afterwards
and i'll see you there in a few minutes
thank you everyone for attending this
webinar and live q a
uh so i'm marina foshock over the next
15 minutes
or so we're going to be answering uh the
questions submitted by the audience
so let's get started
uh so thanks for all of you who've
already submitted some questions
please keep them coming uh i'll start
with a question that is kind of related
to
one of the questions that was asked here
uh about are all the bugs that we find
always fixed um so you know one thing
you may wonder
is uh can wrestler report false
positives
um so
the answer is it depends on your api in
most cases we do not see false positives
but it's possible that with some of the
checkers and with how you've designed
your api uh
that you may see some some bugs reported
by wrestler that
you may choose not to fix so um before
that
for any error you know you may
you may see some bugs being reproducible
and some not and as i mentioned in the
talk wrestler does
uh uh try its best to uh you know
reproduce a couple of times and report
to you
um whether or not it was reproducible
uh an example of a false positive would
be
for its namespace
checker when it's checking you know
different authorizations
sometimes services if you query for a
resource that you're not authorized to
view
they will return to you like an empty
list of resources with a 200 status code
uh well wrestler uh is expecting you to
return
you know a 404 or some error status code
saying that you know really this you've
done something
that you shouldn't access uh so this is
an example
where if your service is designed like
that then um
the way that you would get uh rid of
those false positives for your services
you would go and
modify the um the namespace checker
just to to handle that particular
case and all the checkers have a
specific api that you can use to
basically exclude cases that
are by design in your api
all right it looks like we have a new
question come in
see does wrestler cover
security vulnerabilities in api
endpoints such as the oauth top 10
okay thank you that's a great question
so um
wrestler actually we started this
project in uh 2017
and this was before uh this great list
of the owasp api top 10 came out
uh so specifically uh where wrestlers
most relevant is going to be
for testing rest apis
and a bunch of those wrestler does cover
so um
i won't have a chance to go through them
in detail in as part of this q a but
that's certainly something we can add to
our faq
and uh one thing to call out is that
there are uh you know
uh there's some checks like for example
uh sql injection
that uh wrestler does not include out of
the box and this is because they're
already
uh other great tools that exist to uh to
test for those
um so one possibility for um
you know some some of these checks that
wrestler doesn't cover would be also to
use wrestler to generate the traffic
because wrestler is great at taking an
api specification and you know getting
deeply
into the service in terms of coverage
and then you could use
you could send that traffic and use use
that in conjunction with the
other tools uh that are out there for
testing sql injections to send you know
inject those specific uh
specific payloads
okay great uh it looks like there's
another question that just came in
a question about producer consumer
dependency
how do you include an id created by one
endpoint
in the payload of a consuming endpoint
right so
um this is uh showed a little bit of
that in the demo
the way that you do that is through
these annotations
and so specifically you refer either by
name or by jsonpath
to one id this is your producer and the
other id which is your consumer
so the one id is going to come from the
response and the second one is going to
uh be the one specified to a request uh
and we have some documentation on on
github for how to do that
but we we should provide uh pretty
complete uh
uh kind of hooks for you to do that in
in terms of what what you can express as
part of the swagger schema or open api
schema
uh awesome another question that
uh you know i was thinking would be good
to cover that we didn't talk about
is you may wonder like how long does it
take to run wrestler
so if i uh you know if i want to run
wrestler as part of my csd pipeline
or you know just do like a very thorough
kind of fuzzing run on a regular basis
like how long would that take
um and so of course that's going to
largely depend on
how many requests like how large your
api is and then also
how long it takes just to query the
service so wrestler itself
typically isn't the performance
bottleneck uh in
the testing that we've done where you're
you know going out to query
you know some cloud service that's
deployed elsewhere it's not like all
done on the same machine
uh so for you know a very complex
service
uh with you know a couple hundred
requests with very complicated bodies
etc
uh we see in test mode which is just
this initial mode
to see what requests are covered it can
take
you know half an hour to an hour
um and then once you get into these uh
fuzzing modes like fuzzling where you're
running the checkers
if you have very complicated bodies you
know this can take up to like uh
12 hours or more uh but there are a lot
of knobs
that you can turn on and off to uh
to budget your fuzzing so for example
wrestler by default will have all
combinations of parameters
up to a certain bound and you can try to
increase or decrease that bound
uh and the checkers individually
likewise you can turn checkers on and
off and then the checkers also have a
bound
and then another thing that wrestler
allows you to do is uh
kind of use regular expressions to
restrict even which requests you're
testing
so say if you if you wanted to include
this in ci cd
and you have some kind of a change
uh kind of notification that you're able
to uh
give wrestler to say hey i actually only
changed the code that's associated with
this one api
certainly you could do that in the case
of specification changes uh
pretty easily then you can tell wrestler
to like really only fuzz that api
and its dependencies and it'll figure
all of that out for you
all right cool uh there's some new
questions that just came in
let's see
how can we identify uniquely requests
generated from the wrestler tools so
that if the proxy file
all has to whitelist such requests we
can do that uh so wrestler
does send a specific header which you
can use
i don't remember specifically what is
all included in that header i believe
it's like wrestler and then the version
uh so that's definitely uh that
definitely
should be possible um let's see does
wrestlers support fuzzing json documents
based on a json schema
have you found interesting classes of
bugs presented
solely via the http request
bodies so the answer is yes and yes
and actually in the resources section
there should be a link to our fsc 2020
paper
where we have some case studies that are
specifically
for uh fuzzing the uh payload bodies
which are uh sent as json
uh so we had to kind of address that
problem and design
um json fuzzer that's both taking the
schema into account
as well as the fuzz values and for the
latter
we have um some feedback directed kind
of fuzzing
um which you may be uh you know familiar
with uh from other types of fuzzing um
so uh we have a form of coverage guided
fuzzing where we use
the uh error code and error message as
sort of a an indicator of um
how well we're exercising you know all
the error handling code that's
associated with these different
uh json uh schema variants
and the different values that we've
assigned um
and uh you know i would say in terms of
the type of bugs that we have been found
that we found and a lot of those have
been
uh you know basically uh input
validation
uh type bugs uh it's been so far the
largest uh generator of bugs in terms of
uh what wrestler is able to find
so if it does find lots of different uh
lots of issues
uh and i i think you know the one
interesting thing here also has been
um that we've seen that these bodies
don't always match
like what's in the specification so
sometimes
this fuzzer actually is able to find
like valid
bodies that uh you know don't correspond
to the specification just because it's
trying all these variations of json so
it's uh it's been kind of interesting to
look at some of that data
all right cool uh hope that answers the
question
and you can also reach us on github for
more data on on this specific checker
uh also can the request be rate limited
let's say only 10 to 20 requests per
minute yes uh so
there's a delay that you can specify i
believe it's in the engine settings
and then there's also a delay that you
can specify only for resources being
created
that'll basically help you address rate
limiting type
issues the the the more difficult issue
that
um we don't handle super well right now
is
the case where the resources are
uh there's there's a hard resource limit
say you can create five resources only
of this type
because the algorithm kind of expects
you know you create some resources and
then asynchronously you're cleaning them
up and as long as it's within reasonable
time um
there's no specific count of resources
that we're trying to adhere to
so uh so that that's one issue that you
may run into but as far as like a
kind of timing base rate limiting uh
should be able to handle that
um let's see is schema validation a
subset of this uh fuzz testing so uh
today it is not a subset of the
this fuzz testing um you know again
there there's
uh some other tools that exist for uh
validating
schema against requests but uh you know
this is a pretty popular
uh kind of a request that we've heard so
we may add this in the future
cool thank you for all the great
questions
uh let's see um you know one other thing
that um
you know might be good to mention is um
what's like a typical use case for
wrestler today that we've seen
um because they do kind of quite very
uh so you know initially when we started
uh
we definitely thought about a lot of it
as uh you know this um
much more automated way to do strong
security testing for apis
and so that is still one use case where
um you know people
basically want to fuzz the heck out of
their api they have a specification
and this allows you to achieve like
pretty pretty good coverage out of the
box
so um you know you can still kind of get
a read on the
on the quality that way um even without
a lot of upfront work writing a grammar
and such
um another use case we've seen is where
um there's just like one specific
security checker that people are really
interested in
possibly modifying you know this the
security checkers that we have
uh to um to add their own or to extend
uh one of ours
and um you know this you know can be
pretty powerful
like you can apply that to all of your
apis in your
say organization that you know has a
certain class of bug that maybe
um is not included in wrestler out of
the box to check for
uh and then another kind of um
you know large use case that we've seen
recently
is uh this uh case of using wrestler for
uh regression or differential testing
like for example if you have your
service deployed in many different
regions and
you just want to make sure that they're
always consistent they're offering the
same experience
so baseline and then
you basically just make sure that their
uh their differential testing is
isn't producing you any new new diffs on
a daily basis
um all right
great any more any more questions from
the audience at this point
all right thank you all for attending
today we appreciate your participation
and interest in the topic of improving
cloud service security and reliability
by fuzzing rest apis
um so if you're interested in learning
more we have listed some resources in
the resource list to the right of your
screen
including our github repo and some of
our publications
and we really look forward to seeing how
you build on this research
we hope the tool will be useful to you
if you're facing the problem of testing
cloud services through the rest api and
please let us know
what you think please continue to
interact with us on github after this
talk
thanks again for attending and have a
great day